bonjour je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
matière grise nous nous intéressons un
point particulier sur le cerveau dans
les épisodes précédents vous avez
proposé qu'on s'intéresse aux mensonges
et justement aujourd'hui mans justement
quand tu t'appelles pas du tout fabien
olicard non ça c'est vrai olivier
merci michel je t'en prie sébastien le
mensonge vous l'aurez compris c'est
vraiment le sujet du jour bienvenue dans
matière grise
[Musique]
dans cet épisode vous allez vivre quatre
expériences expérience une les dieux du
mensonge expérience 2 le meilleur alibi
expérience 3 c'est à vous expérience 4
le détecteur de mensonges le tout avec
la présence s'est apprécié de maths les
i
[Musique]
nous mensonge un concept fascinant de
duperie qui passe par le langage
impossible de savoir quand a été
prononcé le premier mensonge de
l'humanité mais une chose est sûre le
mensonge peut avoir des formes
différentes par exemple mentir sur une
donnée ou mentir par omission en ne
donnant pas toutes les données
volontairement nous allons nous
confronter à une énigme que vous
connaissez peut-être si vous la
découvrirez pour la toute première fois
vous allez comprendre comment on peut
intégrer la possibilité d'un mensonge à
notre raisonnement il y a deux personnes
l'une d'elles ment en permanence mais
nous ne pouvons pas savoir qui c'est à
l'avance les deux personnes parlent dans
votre langue et peuvent répondre à des
questions complexes pourtant vous pouvez
déjouer tous leurs mensonges
expérience une mc on va parler d'énigmes
mais d'énigmes qui intègre le mensonge
d'accord on peut intégrer le mensonge à
une réflexion on peut se dire peut-être
qu'on moment et comment je peux intégrer
ce peut-être qu'on moment à ma réflexion
pour être sûr de trouver un résultat
d'accords bienvenue devant les portes du
paradis et de l'enfer
quand il ya de l'un à l'autre c'est
binaire dans mon énigmes devant ses deux
portes il ya deux gardiens ils sont en
tout point identique et voici ce que dit
mon énigme elle dit que l'une des deux
porte mène à l'enfer l'auto paradis on
sait pas laquelle elle dit que l'un des
gardiens dit toujours la vérité l'autre
gardien dit toujours un mensonge on ne
sait pas lequel non plus on a le droit
de poser qu'une seule question à l'un
des deux gardiens et avec leur réponse
il faut déduire qu'elle est la porte du
paradis lundi toujours la vérité et
l'autre ment toujours et l'autre m'ont
toujours et je n'ai le droit de ne poser
qu'une seule question alors on va poser
la question la plus simple si je pose la
question à celui ci est ce la porte du
paradis et qu'il me dit oui soit c'est
le monteur et donc ce n'est pas la porte
du paradis soit ce n'est pas le menteur
donc c'est la porte du paradis donc on
voit que typiquement cette question de
base ne résout absolument rien
exactement il faut les trouver il faut
que je trouve une réponse qui me permet
de terminer si la personne ment ou si
elle ne ment pas
est-ce que c'est forcément le menteur
qui garde la porte de l'enfer non pas
nécessairement voilà donc je pourrais
peut-être en une seule question savoir
quelle est la personne qui m'aurait
celles qui ne m'ont pas mais ça ne m'a
dit craint pas pour autant qu'elle est
la porte du paradis ou qu'est la porte
de l'enfer il suffit de lui dire par
exemple est-ce que je suis devant vous
c'est la passion non on sait que c'est
un menteur est là mais on n'a pas la
porte donc il faut que je trouve une
question qui regroupe les deux
exactement mais ça peut être une
question à tiroirs là où tu commence à
toucher du doigt quelque chose c'est que
si tu regroupe les deux tu es sûr d'une
chose c'est d'avoir un mensonge comme
réponse alors la solution c'est de
demander à l'un ce que va répondre
l'autre alors ça c'est malin ton voisin
garde-t-il la porte du paradis
excellente question voilà alors donc
voilà c'est dit si celui ci en voisin
garde-t-il apporte liberati si tu veux
le faire des tests alors ton voisin un
garde qu'il la porte du paradis si celui
ci je dis vrai il va me dire oui
effectivement il garde la porte du
paradis donc je peux y aller voilà si
celui ci est le menteur et que les qu'il
me dit oui le voisin garde de la porte
oui mon voisin garde de la porte du
paradis oui mais ça peut dès lors il
peut très bien mon tir et ça peut être
très bien la porte de l'enfer donc c'est
exactement ça alors tu vois on regarde
on va rajouter une dernière nuit c'est
si je demande à ton voisin
s'il garde la porte du paradis que
va-t-il me répondre
si je demande à ton voisin s'il garde la
porte du paradis que va-t-il me répondre
hélas sans même faire les tests qui va
vite se rendre compte que s'il me dit la
vérité lui bah il va répondre le
mensonge de l'autre puisque que va-t-il
me répondre et si lui moment si c'est le
menteur il va pas me donner la vérité
puisque cet inventeur donc il va me
mentir sur la réponse de l'autre oui
donc dans les deux cas je vais avoir un
mensonge comme réponse et moi il me
suffira donc du coup de fer linverse que
vam à répondre ton voisin si je lui
demande s'il garde la porte du paradis
voilà la bonne question à poser pour
savoir où est la porte du paradis est
alors pour la petite histoire on m'a
posé cette énigme quand j'avais 15 ans
je n'ai jamais trouvé la réponse
parce que c'est notre manière de penser
en fait c'est notre manière de réfléchir
et en fait qui s'explique très bien avec
des mathématiques plus qu'avec des mots
c'était une petite initiation aux
mensonges de si on est sûr qu'il ya une
donnée qui conclut quelque part mais
qu'on sait pas quelles données on peut
quand même établir des hypothèses de
résultats en se disant ok il faut que
j'intègre toujours le fait que yens
données corrompues dans le système et
c'est intéressant pour beaucoup de
systèmes tu vois de de se dire bon je
sais qu'il ya un loup stick dans le tas
qui a changé quelque chose est-ce que je
peux quand même tirer quelque chose du
reste quoi et oui effectivement le
mensonge se glissent peut se glisser
dans beaucoup de raisonnement
scientifique cas aussi les présentations
et rogner fallacieuse etc et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut vraiment lire toute la
production scientifique le voit beaucoup
de sujets qui m'intéressent
effectivement en se disant attention
est-ce qu'il ya pas un mensonge quelque
part et notamment aidé a souvent une
corruption du raisonnement qui vient
souvent qui est qui et de quoi confondre
associations et causalité c'est pas
parce que tu observes une association
entre deux facteurs que tu voir une
causalité d'un facteur par rapport à
l'autre et ça c'est une erreur
heureusement que beaucoup de gens
commettent très souvent merci pour cette
première expérience
il faut comprendre que lorsque l'on sait
qu'une donnée est corrompu il suffit de
l'intrigué avec l'autre donnée pour
ensuite conclure que le résultat est
faux et faire linverse ça va toujours
vous c'est une manière de réfléchir très
différentes mais très stimulante pour
notre cerveau maintenant que vous avez
fait chauffer vos neurones s'il a
clairement nous allons faire quelque
chose de plus ressenti des masques et
les menteurs juste après évidemment ce
placement de produits de la marque
fabien olicard comme toujours
sur l'icc art grand prix a essayé vous
on dit souvent qu'une image vaut mieux
que mille mots cet interrogatoire va
être très
hype
musclé ou et me dire où vous étiez en
janvier vers 20 heures début janvier
vers 20 heures gt gt ou c'était du
cateau 8 était à nantes à la compagnie
du café-théâtre ya quelqu'un qui peut
corroborer les faits bah pas qu'un peu
wayne ti bonne âme parce que c'était
complet c'est un théâtre au moins 70
personnes par soir parce que c'est des
grosses salles que je suis en ce moment
ce que fait un spectacle qui s'appelle
en création donc c'est le processus de
création du nouveau spectacle des cinq
soirs du cateau 8 ça fait cinq soirs où
il ya des gens qui peuvent dire j'étais
non non ça se tient j'espère bien ses
soutiens non je veux dire le spectacle
ça tient à this tient pas mal ça va en
fait on a déjà fait 20% de la création
tous les soirs sont différents mais ça
commence à avoir une structure c'est
c'est un peu un labo créative c'est
chouette vivre et avoir aussi je pense
d'accord j'ai une autre question pour
vous pour voir si vous avez réponse à
tous deux soient douces pas du tout
entre mars et avril ça j'avais la
réponse mars et avril entre 20h vous
serez au de cette année ouais peux vous
dire où je serai avec mon spectacle à
poissy à côté d'annecy le 10 mars air
gai gaborik et ce à côté de quimper le
18 mars alors je rentrais en alien
contre laval et le montrent ces 19 mars
à saint nabord sa côté de colmar le 26
mars à strasbourg le 14 avril à chaumont
à côté troyes le 15 avril c'est quand
même marrant vous ayez un alibi sur
toutes ces dates sont intéressés mais
landry tournée mais c'est sur des dates
où il ya un crime qui va être commis oui
j'ai des minority report monsieur ouais
ouais et on met en juin entre 21 vous
saurez où ça c'est une question pas
c'est toujours une question pour moi et
je serais je sais mais je serai lance le
3 mai à fourmies la frontière belge le 4
mai dunkerque 5 mai à denain ce à côté
de valenciennes le 6 mai à lille ville à
côté de lille très bon en jeu le 7 mai
saint raphaël celles à côté de cannes le
27 mai à nantes le 1er juin
saint-cyr-sur-loire ses proches de tours
le 2 juin genève le 9 juin marseille le
17 juin toulon le 18 juin et à besançon
bleus le 30 juin ce sera la fin de la
tournée création dans les petites salles
sera terminée après très bien très bien
si jamais on veut vous surveiller de
loin en étendant la salle on peut
acheter ses billets en ligne où l'on
regardé comme un petit job specter oui
le lien est dans la description comme
c'est ma tournée je vous mets le lien
dans la description mais c'est que c'est
quoi l'objet de votre recherche jude ne
sait plus du tout ce pour quoi je vous
interroge mais peut-être que c'est pour
répondre à la fameuse question qu'on
pose toujours la fin des spectacles
quand je parle avec le public quelle est
elle il n'est pas là loïc peut-être que
je serai là mais pour vous surveiller
[Musique]
soyez attentifs la prochaine expérience
nous allons voir qu'il n'est pas si
simple de démasquer un menteur ou une
menteuse mais que cela reste possible de
faire une hypothèse je parle d'
hypothèse car on ne peut jamais être
certain à 100% qu'une personne ment
alors mac on va avoir quatre personnes
qui vont se défiler devant nous oui qui
vont nous raconter une anecdote de leur
vie bien j'ai un problème c'est que je
sais qu'il ya un auteur ou une menteuse
pathologique dans le tas alors que les
autres sont très honnêtes mais j'arrive
pas encore à identifier qui donc on va
devoir ensemble trouver qui ment parmi
ces quatre personnes je vais faire de
mon mieux on va les appeler à la barre
tout installé comme sa première personne
ce sera crise bonjour je hante écoute
pour ton anecdote alors mon anecdote
c'est que j'ai fait de la prison aux
états unis bancal pénitencier c'est une
bonne question c'était en alabama je
veux demander de vous mettre sur le côté
on reviendra sur lui si on a besoin ça
déjà c'est la première chose qui est
très bien c'est de demander un détail
particuliers plus le détail est
compliqué plus on peut apprécier un
petit peu le degré d ans ce mode
bonjour on à l'exode elle est toute
simple c'est que j'ai déjà pris un
couteau dans le dos
combien jours de travail à 0 c'était
pendant les vacances merci monsieur
clément et bonjour j'étais la doublure
piano david hallyday sur quel piano à je
ne suis pas la marque du piano j'étais
juste une douleur je ne sais pas j'ai
deux pianos
et inès
bonjour bonjour alors qu'il est en
anecdotes ines j'ai failli mourir d'une
pneumonie le piémont et virales ou
bactériennes alors ça une pneumonie
tu veux pas travailler ou à l'hôpital je
crois je crois que c'était ça c'était
quand longtemps très longtemps genre
c'est très longtemps tu étais enfant oui
parce que tu peux nous raconter un petit
peu comment tu as vécu cette période là
mon père était en voyage et
ma mère devait me garder et en fait
j'étais alité depuis
depuis quelques jours et quand mon père
est rentré qu'il a vu que j'étais
complètement
apathique il il m'a emmené aux urgences
et et on n'a pas voulu me prendre tout
de suite en charge et du coup fait tout
tout un truc pour pouvoir dire mon
enfant va mourir enfin d'autres comme ça
voilà donc voilà j'ai failli mourir
d'une pneumonie merci naissent alors toi
là il ya un truc qui est intéressant
c'est que quand je dis comment tu le
vivait elle elle nous raconte que son
père est en voyage sa mère faisait ci
faisait ça c'est pas des détails utiles
en fait et c'est en général le menteur
ne prend pas le temps de fabriquer tous
et historique là à part le menteur
pathologique atteint mythomanie en
général on va droit au but parce qu'on
veut juste convaincre de quelque chose
on va faire revenir crise peut-être dû à
des questions à lui poser pourquoi tu as
fait la prison parce que j'allais
vous êtes est uni pour un tournage d'une
publicité
et je suis arrivé à la frontière et ils
m'ont demandé ce que je venais faire
comme toujours et j'ai répondu avec
beaucoup d'assurance harry how to shoot
tony parker parce que je faisais un
tournage avec tony parker et shoot veut
dire filmé mais aussi bon et ils n'ont
pas trop apprécié la raison de ma venue
et donc ils m'ont embarqué peux tu nous
donner ton il dîne tong itinéraire
depuis la france jusqu'à la rencontre
avec tony parker oui j'ai fait
paris/amsterdam
amsterdam los angeles et ensuite on a
fait los angeles jusque dans la mare en
voiture tu as dit que tu avais fait la
prison de là bas ma part ce que au
passage de la frontière vous avez
demandé ce que tu as les faits aux etats
unis c'est là que les touches au tony
parker alors je vois que la frontière tu
l'a passée à l'arrivée à l'aéroport à
los angeles et c'est pourtant en alabama
très loin de los angeles que tu vas être
emprisonné quelques heures ouais parce
qu'au début ils ont laissé passer et il
faut arriver en alabama
il ya eu des réels problèmes sur le
tournage et du coup ils sont venus la
police est venue et quand on passe la
frontière en fait on en est fiché et du
coup ils ont pris mais il manque
d'identité et c'est là qu'ils ont vu qu'
il y avait eu un problème à la frontière
là il ya quelque chose d'intéressant sur
crise pareille dans les faits ce de la
psychologie du mensonge c'est qu'en
général un menteur regarde beaucoup dans
les yeux ses interlocuteurs en fait
quand on raconte une anecdote on ne fait
que décrocher le regard parce qu'on a
besoin de se rappeler un petit peu un
motard a pas besoin de faire ça et
inconsciemment ou consciemment il a
besoin de regarder le visage des gens
pensent dire est ce qu'ils sont en train
de me croire écrit savez tendance est
comme ça on fait revenir clément clément
bien sûr
alors que faisait david hallyday pendant
ce temps là c'est ça eh ben il faisait
sa chanson en play-back pour une
émission musicale sur la chaîne m6 ah
oui donc c'était une émission musicale
et donc c'était juste pour faire un plan
plus concise amendé il fallait quelqu'un
en fait derrière le piano il y avait des
musiciens d'emprunt en fait qu'ils
étaient embauchés sur le tournage on m'a
dit bah tiens y'a pas le pianiste qu'est
ce que tu peux venir te médias le piano
merci clément parce qu intéressant pour
clémence et qu' ils cherchent pas nous
en mettre plein les mirettes
tu vois ce que je veux dire oui en
général modeste oui et quand même qu'on
veut mentir on essaie d'en mettre un
petit peu plus on va refaire venir mode
parce qu'il n'a pas beaucoup parlé toi
tout à l'heure à quel moment on se
retrouve avec un couteau dans le dos
dans la vie et bah c'était les vacances
on était entre amis et voilà c'est mon
ex copain qui est responsable de ça à
l'origine
en fait il m'a poussé et il y avait un
couteau ranger mal rangés dans une
glacière et je me suis emballé dessus
quoi j'ai le couteau est rentré
profondément bois de à peu près ça en
fait ce qui m'a sauvé c'est qu' il est
rentré dans une côte et à partir du
moment où
le couteau planté que ce qui se passe
concrètement je vais pas mentir la
soirée a été un peu avancée donc on
était tous un peu éméché et je sens que
j'ai mal il ya quelque chose qui ne va
pas et en me relevant je passe la main
dans mon dos est en fait en faisant ça
je vois que c'est tout rouge et je
comprends qu'il ya un problème parce que
j'ai mal et j'aurai du sang sur ma main
ce qui est marrant c'est qu'on savait
pas en fait comment je m'étais blessé
avant que mon ex petit copain
voit dans la glacière le couteau sortie
dressées vers le ciel là on a fait le
lien tout de suite à les pompiers les
urgences etc et voilà ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'en lui posant une
question elle nous déroule quand même
son histoire elle mais elle fait
travailler toutes ces mémoires
d'ailleurs tu vois et ça nous sert aussi
de bons points de comparaison avec crise
ou en finale est-ce que tu serais
capable d'expliquer ce qui s'est passé
et toi porte crise non je trouve qu'il
ya des incohérences dans ce danseur ici
nous dit qu'il va pour faire un tournage
tony parker to shoot tony parker c'est
la clé les policiers de la frontière ce
qui est assez crédible serait sage que
les crédits peu fait attendre on va
vérifier ça ils incarcèrent quelques
heures et puis en fait on s'aperçoit que
il est en train de tourner déjà avec une
publicité avec des fusils pour tony
parker qui a un souci que des policiers
viennent pour l'interroger que ils
étaient fichés je pense que les
policiers américains ont autre chose à
faire savoir qu'ils aient fichiers etc
voilà n'ai pas besoin de retourner à la
frontière pour à perth pour s'apercevoir
que ne vienne états-unis donc ce récit
me semble incohérent je pense que chris
et le montant je pense ceci tu as raison
une crise avancé à la barre des accusés
chris mac lesggy mettait pas en prison
s'il vous plaît mac lesggy vous accuse
de mensonges éhontés et c'est tout à
fait faux que que l'histoire est totale
oui parce que là du coup c'était pas
clair pardon dont l'histoire est tout à
fait fausses fera pas tout à fait fausse
j'ai réellement
était faire une publicité avec tony
parker à los angeles j'ai vraiment dit
ça te donner cette raison de même comme
une chute tony parker à los angeles ils
ont bougé jusqu'à ce que je leur montre
la caméra et qui comprennent et ils
m'ont laissé passer vous le côté très
crédible de ce passage là en fait j'ai
un enjeu enfin enjolivé tu as tiré une
histoire qui était réellement passé
l'erreur que tu as fait c'était de dire
alabama g10 alabama mais vraiment pas ce
que vous m'avez posé la question de quel
centre pénitentiaire et de mon cerveau a
fait le buzz j'ai fait ou là quoi je
sais pas je sais pas pourquoi j'ai pas
dis los angeles qu'il est beaucoup plus
crédible parce que dans le fond attendu
dédié à la ben ammar mode ces paumés
persona connaît il saura pas tetris est
pas le placer sur une canne un mois
car
voilà du coup de mon cerveau a buggé
j'ai dit à la mamma et à partir de là
bas c'était fini vous m'avez piéger les
d'ailleurs s'attendre étape c'est
typique des personnes qui m'ont ce qui
qui qui montent comme ça sur une
anecdote c'est à dire de vite aller dans
des endroits en espérant que la personne
ne suivent pas et après dès que tu
cherches à creuser tu as toujours en
face on le voit dans la psychologie de
mensonges d'espèces de battage nantes a
pas compris c'est parce que c'est une
phrase qui revient souvent oui non mais
ça c'est parce que blablabla alors que
si c'est cohérent y'a jamais besoin de
dire oui mais non est là où tu as raison
et je m'en étais jamais fait la
réflexion c'est que quand on pose des
questions dans les trois autres cas le
récit c'était clair si bien s'ils
deviennent de plus en plus cohérente
salons cossus du christ devenait de
moins en moins cohérent peut-être le
signe du mensonge tard sgs merci d'avoir
jeu que je remercie tout le monde et
bravo mac abattoirs
[Applaudissements]
pas facile de trouver team ans dans la
réalité vous pouvez le confondre plus
facilement en augmentant sa charge
cognitive pour cela nous avons à
disposition entre autres les différents
travaux de alder breach professeur de
psychologie sociale appliquée est
reconnu comme l'un des plus grands
spécialistes mondiaux de la psychologie
du mensonge tout d'abord soyez
pleinement à l'ecoute fixé intensément
votre interlocuteur pour montrer que
vous l'écoutez très attentivement cela
peut le mettre mal à l'aise ciment
laissez le parler et ne le coupent et
que très peu plus une personne parle
plus les risques de cafouillage sont
grands vous pouvez aussi demander des
détails dans une chronologie différente
de l'histoire d'origine il est très
complexe de revenir à des endroits
précis d'un mensonge
tout à l'heure nous verrons les signaux
physiologiques du mensonge très
intéressant mais juste après le c'est à
vous
[Musique]
alors le principe du cetab ou max et que
je te pose des questions mais je leur
pose en même temps oui vous vous
répondez dans les commentaires aymaq lui
répond sincèrement n'y a rien à gagner
mais c'est notez bien
question une chaire mac est ce que tu
penses que les animaux ou que des
animaux peuvent mentir et ça vous mentir
oui oui avec l'intention du mensonge à
la question de l' intention chez
l'animal est une question qui est qui
est complexe plus on avance en éthologie
dans les recherches sur l'intelligence
animale plus on s'aperçoit qu'elle est
étendue s'exprime pas sur le plan de
l'intelligence humaine sur d'autres
plans donc avec l'intention du mensonge
par exemple pour échapper à un prédateur
oui je pense qu'il ya une
intentionnalité une conscience du
mensonge chez certains animaux et bien
tu as tout à fait bien répondu tout ça
que j'ai pour exemple les mouches qui
pour détourner l'attention par exemple
de la femelle les mâles vont lui offrir
un cadeau alors début il faisait un
petit cocon de soie où il était un petit
homme au début ils apportaient de la
nourriture sont ni s'apprend pas assez
de temps ils ont enrobé dans un cocon de
soie qui sont dits baisse apprend
toujours pas de temps le déballage s'est
passé de temps donc ils ont fait un
énorme cocon de soie et là ça prenait
beaucoup de temps et du coup les mouches
se sont dit pourquoi je mets un truc
dans le cocon le temps qu'elle déballe
est donc maintenant ils mettent la
mouche mais un petit caillou par exemple
dans le cocon de soie la mouche semaine
le reçoit le secoue l entend quelque
chose et le temps qu'elle ouvre la
bouche mal fait son oeuvre et s'en va et
dont il ya un vrai mensonge il ya un
vrai but de d'obtenir quelque chose via
ce mensonge donc c'est vrai chez cet
animal chez plein d'autres questions 2
selon les études les femmes manquent
plus souvent que les hommes vrais faux
je pense que c'est je pense que c'est
vrai non pas parce que elle aurait donc
c'est un avis purement personnel je
pense que c'est vrai non pas parce
qu'elle aurait une propension à mentir
plus forte qu'eux
mais les hommes mais je suis sûr que des
femmes verbalise plus est par le plus
que le que des hommes ça les études le
disent dans une conversation femmes ont
tendance à parler plus et donc je pense
que récurent amant elles sont conduites
par ce fait à mon cas puisque les hommes
ok donc ton raisonnement c'est par
exemple quelqu'un qui conduit beaucoup
sa voiture a plus de chances d'avoir un
accident donc quelqu'un qui parle le
plus a plus de chance de me mentir entre
guillemets en quelque sorte alors le
raisonnement est bon mais l'étude de
2009 qui a été fait par la fox dit que
les hommes manquent plus souvent que les
femmes et dans cette étude on apprend
par contre que les femmes qui mentent ou
qui ont établi un mensonge 82% d'entre
elles ressentent des scrupules des
remords ça c'est intéressant alors que
pour les hommes c'est moins de 70% par
contre ça c'est une autre étude qui est
qu'il l'a confirmé c'est une étude du
musée de la science à londres noko final
les hommes par le moins mais mangent
plus et ont moins de scrupules au final
un flan qu'on s'améliore pour ce média
question 3 on peut reconnaître un moteur
sur la mélodie de savoie est ce que tu
sais comment peut-être qui va avoir
tendance je le verrais assez bien de
monter dans les aigus parler d'une voix
plus plus fait plus élevé que si lisez
la vérité je vois pas un menteur dit non
non j'ai fait de la prison en alabama
j'en suis plutôt les oui j'ai fait la
prison n'aurait pas ma donc j'irai qui
monte dans les aigus tu as tout à fait
raison donc si la prosodie qui nous
lundi qu'un intensité la hauteur la
vitesse de la voit donc les menteurs ont
tendance à parler un peu plus vite et
comme tu le disais à monter dans les
aigus c'est pas tant le mensonge
d'ailleurs qu'on étudie dans ces moments
là parce qu'on n'est pas capable de le
détecter comme une science dure par
contre c'est la variation des motions en
fait ainsi la gêne qui nous fait
accéléré qui nous fait monter dans les
aigus quatrième alors 4e c'est un peu
sous la forme d'une énigme imagine que
mac tu es dans une soirée de mariage et
croise deux personnes qui sont manon est
clair tu sais que l'une des deux est
marié et l'autre non comme tu veux
savoir laquelle est marié tu leur pose
la question et manon répond je suis
marié
alors que klee a répond je ne le suis
pas et tu sais que l'une au moins l'une
des deux mains est ce que tu peux
décider est ce que tu peux déterminer
leur statut matrimonial manon d'y être
marié oui si elle ment clair dit la
vérité elle n'est pas mariée donc aucun
d'eux n'est maric si c'est maintenant
clair qui ment en disant elle n'est pas
mariée elle est mariée et comme c'est
elle qui m'ont et que manon dit la
vérité elle est donc mariés elles aussi
ont fait d'eux qu'ils sont mariés donc
je suis
maintenant je te redonne l'énoncé oui et
peut-être ça devrait peut-être débloquer
dans une sereine mariage vous croisez
manon et cléa vous savez que l'une des
deux est marié l'autre n'ont jusque là
tablé très bon comme vous voulez savoir
laquelle vous leur posez la question
maintenant répond je suis mariée il ya
répond je ne le suis pas ça serait plus
simple si vous ne saviez pas que l'une
au moins des deux ment pouvez vous me
dire leur statut matrimonial la réponse
est
non je ne peux pas te dire leur statut
matrimonial et c'est tout à fait correct
ou la deuxième réponse possible attendue
et elle manque probablement toutes les
deux et ça c'est intéressant parce que
dans ce genre d'énigme souvent on se
raccroche à ce qu'on connaît de ce genre
d'énigme et donc c'est presque notre
cerveau qui nous ment à nous mêmes en
déterminant qui a forcément une kim en
est une qui dit la vérité exacte alors
que ça peut être les documents oui parce
que tu as dit il y en a au moins une vie
des documents absolue li na pali l'union
et l'autre pas et là j'aurais dû dire
cette limite a posé cette fois ci je me
suis arrêté au fait de lier rien n' des
documents il y en a au moins des
documents je les traduis part il y en a
une des documents voilà il mon erreur
est là c'est assez marrant aussi de voir
comment on se recréer des cadres un
petit peu sociale parfois alors qu'il
faut pas hésiter si on voit une
impossibilité en sortir pour se dire
attentes est-ce que c'est pas un réflexe
de penser que j'ai maintenant c'est
intéressant
la manipulation de la fausse information
n'est pas une chose simple par contre
tous les jeux de bluff comme time bomb
par exemple où il faut mentir et
argumenter son très bon pour l'esprit et
pour le développement cognitif de votre
cerveau voilà au moins un avantage aux
mensonges comme il est utilisé dans le
cadre d'un jeu il améliore de plein de
manières différentes votre cerveau et
consomme pas mal d'énergie oui réfléchir
en plus ça fait maigrir
[Musique]
mais peut-on détecter le mensonge par
les réactions du corps et du visage et
si oui est-ce qu'une machine peut
vraiment le faire on va équiper mac d'un
détecteur de mensonges pour regarder ça
plus près pour cette expérience j'ai
appelé à la rescousse baptiste et artus
connu sous le nom des frères poulain ces
bricoleurs hors pair on construit un
réel polygraphe une machine à détecter
le mensonge
si les secrets de cet appareil vous
intéresse pour retrouverez toutes les
étapes de fabrication directement sur
leur chaîne youtube en lien dans la
description
pour cette dernière expérience que je
vous avais un petit peu tease et nous
recevons donc les frères poulain si vous
suivez la chaîne depuis longtemps vous
vous savez qu'ils ont fabriqué cet
étrange machine qui viennent de mettre
sur mac alors déjà mac merci de jouer le
jeu je t'en prie faible et c'est cette
machine à l'apport prétention quoi est
ce que tu nous expliques artus bas elle
va analyser un petit peu toutes les
courbes que peuvent dégager un corps
humain le maximum du moins qu'on a
réussi à intégrer sur cette machine donc
on va avoir la dilatation de la pupille
ou avoir le rythme cardiaque on va avoir
la déglutition grâce à un capteur placé
sur la gorge on va avoir aussi
l'oxygénation on va avoir la fréquence
cardiaque et je crois que j'en oublie un
peu trop de sudation le taux de sudation
c'est ça alors ça c'est un très
intéressant c'est que donc c'est qu'on
peut appeler un polygraphe c'est les
détecteurs de mensonges il ya des pays
où on s'en sert réellement pour essayer
de d'avoir des indices dans les
tribunaux en france c'est pas le cas et
on verra pourquoi tout à l'heure mais la
seule chose qu'on sait c'est que du coup
le mensonge on peut pas détecter le
mensonge en lui-même on peut détecter
les variations des réactions corporelle
et c'est ça qu'on va voir sur mac on va
commencer par lui poser des questions
dont nous sommes certains que la réponse
est vrai je t'ai laissé rebâtissent je
t'appelle bien mac lesggy oui tu es un
homme oui tu vis dans le doubs non tu
portes aujourd'hui une une veste oui
elle est de couleur bleu oui tu
travaille aujourd'hui à la télévision
oui principalement et ton métier de
formation ses ingénieurs oui à grenoble
toutes ces données convient d'avoir à
l'image on a vu les oscillations les
courbes on n'a pas vu de pique
surprenant maintenant on va comparer
avec des questions dont on ne connaît
pas forcément la réponse mais qui
peuvent être piégés en stressante
et dans ne sera jamais si si mac nous
ment ou pas donc mac sans toi libres de
nous mentir de nous dire la vérité à
loisir maintenant entendus alors mac tu
portes une paire de baskets oui tu fais
beaucoup de sport beaucoup et du coup
c'est quelque chose que tu apprécies où
c'est plutôt une souffrance a cédé 2
quand on fait du sport etc ont un petit
peu les limites c'est un peu une
souffrance mais c'est aussi un plaisir
parce que on est content d'avoir
souffert nos payes no games l'a déjà ce
que ce qu'on peut commenter et ce qui
est un peu rigolo c'est l'augmentation
de la fréquence cardiaque qui pourrait
nous dire si on regarde juste les
données brutes moi je me dirais tiens il
vient démentir récemment et si on
regarde
la réponse qu'il est qui vient de faire
c'était de l'humour tout simplement donc
en faisant une blague on a des réactions
physiologiques qui changent parce qu'il
ya une excitation il ya l'amusement de
tout ça il ya aussi quand on fait de
l'humour demandé inconsciemment à ce que
la blague elle va faire mouche ou pas
est-ce qu'elle va fonctionner ça peut
générer des petits stress et tout ça
nous donnerait l'impression qu'il a
menti alors qu'il n'a pas de donné une
réverbe table données vient juste de
nous faire une blague quoi
prochaine question s'il vous prochaine
question attend il faut que je trouve
bien moi j'ai une question mack dans le
fond est ce que tu m'aimes vraiment
en fait non non fabien je t'aime papa je
t'aime pas vraiment pour moitié
représentent la jeunesse la jeune
génération celle qui va me pousser
bientôt à la retraite et je déteste
c'est intéressant parce que à chaque
question de toute façon il y est il ya
un peu de stress forcément et donc tout
de suite des débuts de la question la
question n'est pas encore posée une
secte la question va être posée on voit
que et bien les unes à tracer le
graphique il va il parlant tous les sens
par contre après on sent quand même que
ça se stabilise après la question après
on pourrait peut-être décider des petits
pics en utilisant la machine la chose
qu'on a remarqué le plus en fait c'est
quand la question elle est vraiment
sensible en fait on est sensible à la
question ah oui c'est joliment dit oui
c'est à dire qu' on ne peut pas savoir
si c'est un mensonge ou pas mais si on
pose une question très pointu sur un
sujet particulier on sait pas que ça va
toucher à personne mais qu'à une
réaction physique faille ça nous est
déjà arrivé avec maîtrise pour le coup
de poser une question vraiment ciblé et
d'un qu'on se rend compte que la
personne a une réaction très forte je
suis 100% d'accord avec çà et là ce
moment là mais la question c'est qu'on a
touché quelque chose est-ce que derrière
ce qui va raconter c'est la vérité ou
mensonge ça on ne sait pas par contre on
sait que laquelle l'adhésion l' impact
est exactement mais c'est pour ça que la
question fabien baron déstabiliser c'est
ça non mais c'est ça la vérité c'est un
peu plat bon je vais m'en tire pour
rigoler mais en même temps ça peut être
donc voilà il ya cette espèce de micro
stress que tout ça pour dire
effectivement voici pourquoi on se sert
pas du polygraphe de manière
professionnelle parce que tout à l'heure
je vous dise par un être humain qui peut
se vanter de savoir dire quand une
personne ment et bien de la même manière
il n'y a pas une machine qui est capable
de dire quand est ce qu'une personne
ment là que des machines qui savent
relever des données et les données
doivent être interprétés par un être
humain et on en revient au point de
départ il n'y a pas un être humain qui
est capable de dire quand est ce qu'une
personne ment alors ça c'est très
intéressant pour s'amuser on avait déjà
fait sur la chaîne avec avec des
résultats qui étaient plus faciles sur
des choses très factuelle tu vois de
penser à une carte rouge noir ont relevé
les pics de stress mais sur des vraies
questions de choses qui sont pensés qui
sont ressenties qui sont de l'ordre du
souvenir aussi le stress même aussi de
la question d'ici demain ou sillage
poser une question à mac sur qu'est ce
que tu as fait précisément le 13 août
parce que si la réponse ne nous convient
pas on va t'accuser de quelque chose ces
pics de stress vont être intenses
nécessairement en coin donc c'est
marrant comme outil et bravo d'avoir
construit ça mais évidemment ça reste
qu'un jouet
comme vous l'avez constaté il n'y a pas
de réelle fiabilité dans les machines
elles sont là pour fournir des données
uniquement et s'étale l'humain derrière
de les interpréter comme pour tout une
interprétation ne peut pas être fiable à
100% vous merci à tous les participants
à toute l'équipe à sherlock semaine et
updated à la production à loïc à la réal
avec toute son équipe est bien sûr un
mac lesggy n'hésitez pas à découvrir son
émission e égal m6 je vous mettrai le
lien du dernier ripley dans la
description le prochain épisode de
matière grise sera publiée le mois
prochain et la thématique sera la
concentration vous pouvez également vous
abonner gratuitement à la chaîne si
cette série de vidéos vous plaît vous
avez également les 12 autres épisodes
précédents de matière grise dans la
description alors sommes-nous condamnés
à nous faire avoir par les mensonges
pour vous nous les déjouée grâce à la
logique de notre cerveau eh bien nous
verrons ça et bien plus encore dont les
prochains épisodes de matière grise à
très bientôt salut c'est chao en fait
faut arrêter de se faire passer pour moi
un moment donné c'est mon escalier
[Musique]